he's on my channel [__] yes all you
other youtubers out there I wish I could
get a collab of KS I got it yeah just
reading people get pistol stupid boy I'm
good to kill you you know like I've had
situations where I've been bullied
because I'm people you know I've been
black like and it's just it's just one
of those things like I don't want people
to always to put me on this pedal stool
right I want them to treat me like a
normal guy that's the thing you don't
want people who are just yes yes mine
aren't you because you'll then think
you're the [__] and then you will treat
people like [__] to me Mangiamo P o G on
I live here profusely like Godzilla I'm
out here full-blown killer [__]
I'm out yeah I know some girls with me
just because I'm care sigh but then I
just use that to get a bang and then
peace house like just take a [__]
forward me like use literally like
proper series standing in my eyes so I
was like you [__] touch me one more
time I'm gonna [__] kill you shouted
oh my god I'm in your eyes sorry your
eyes actually took my sperm counts
actually it's actually very strong yeah
I had a check once three times the
average man so strong me as a YouTube
video in that there is this is gonna do
it although that all of the Cybermen
wanking into a cuppa and getting the
sperm count yet for more money for Mel
ballast and see who the winners nine
months later is like we're all wait and
roll the bed whose is it
I don't think it'll be vixx but yet
Vikram where you wouldn't expect maybe
sperm or legendary you know
big things by his penis wanna see yeah
like he's the quiet one but of course I
do we are weak or not so we stock will
sort the podcasts on that start sperm
come talk birthday most people on that
birthday you know that may get surprised
party clowns got ksi oh wow what's up
you're coming on you're not actually
available for birthdays I just want to
make that clear unless some billionaire
they wants his son you know have a good
party maybe Bar Mitzvah it's very
possible all right just just really good
good money in trust me
how much would ballpark figure just
saying birthdays in New Castle not as
lucrative right fifty quid and you got
to do like the new Casati balloon Alfie
enough to do like some of those pub
things where you have to sit there 200
quid saw at site
I mean I'd probably do it I'm not saying
no but it's not you got to start stock
that came the money as you start getting
that event circuit going you know we're
not used to these viewing figures so
while we are starting it is my birthday
if you want to give the gift give the
gift of subscription to the YouTube
channel just get in there me remember
subscriptions for life not just for just
for a birthday yeah smash a puss I just
want to say yeah calyx and Kyle fries a
bit harsh on you cuz I was with you the
whole time
yes I like your hat that was if I want
to see what I came away from the video
is like hey Jase maybe we should but ya
know I think we could pull off like for
me I'm always like I love like fashion
and all that so I love my clothes or
normally quite out there yeah yeah so
even while I'm wearing this is like an
oversized hoodie you know and like oh
like this my my character my wear but
you know I just don't care you don't
give a [__] man I always like yeah sort
of the house like [__] it like
[Music]
you look like Joe a little buff shot a
[__] look there yeah the way the great
did it was great God he's a director see
he talks like this a bit you know you
just let him go
alright so honest like get the Weasleys
looking KSA's us we'll get that out the
way I want to say submit three years ago
I watched me first ksi video I'd only
just started doing the job so it was to
the day I uploaded on me on me birthday
actually did you get involved in youth
from from so from the day you uploaded
you went oh this is not I'd started
youtube out a few weeks before huh I'd
like my videos well may sitting on the
couch on the worst camera ever just
drinking a beer shouting about Newcastle
and then I seen Q&A with my girlfriend
and I was like oh I'm really bad at
YouTube actually and I was like this is
what I want if these are the kind of
[__] videos are one of it didn't have
a girlfriend which was annoying with my
hand I've got that could happen I could
do that kind of it's never happened but
it was [__] great I love that one
that's just you know when you see
something and it just it's inspires any
thought alright I can and now three as
there is on my channel [__] yes I got
it yeah I did it just ask him a thousand
tales do that favour in Southampton no I
did I did a rock book free of charge
I did promote it we sell a little bit
too much I'm not joking aside man we
must've been told you know is like 10
times stop promoting yourself
in the morning we're not getting paid
for this event are we all made to worry
about face I'll find a way and I did and
now look over man so mate can I talk to
you about your life go through that's I
want to just I like to start at the
beginning early memories and you got any
what's like you got a third like a first
memory that sticks out with your mind of
like being changing I guess I used to go
to a school then I was like oh maybe
like 2,000 people I was like the second
black guy [__] I know all right I was
pretty mad so you suck a lot yeah you're
quite a well-spoken lot it was a big
school so yeah it was a private school
all right so yeah so my parents mom and
dad put you know they busted they got me
in there yeah so they did then they were
me and sure yeah he's getting an
education it's like they had my mind so
when I was doing the YouTube they're
like dad I'll pay a loan of one database
cause there's so much money he still
hasn't paid all right no fair playin me
obviously we're all kinda know your mom
and dad know you put them in your videos
she don't give a [__] now I love it it's
my life before they used to like care
about everything what they worried yeah
you know the image and all that nowadays
they just all think it's fair to say
they don't video I still to this day
I think I wouldn't take credit for every
[__] do what works but oh what a
[__] what a video that was like it
was absolutely classic but so what do
you think has changed in their mind I do
you think they're just like jenna is
don't take life too seriously it's worth
the money the money the money the money
yeah back then I wasn't making any money
I think the more money you make the less
of a [__] you give that's a graph we can
put together
it's definitely work for me every time
you give so many [__] now because
YouTube's just dead I really don't give
a [__] obviously from the culture I
don't know putting it on from the
culture they come from they do want
people to respect them like that part of
it a generation as it is like trust me
like I don't know if you've heard of
black Twitter I destroyed them like
Twitter constantly like when I did the
hair thing when I styled my hair like
[Music]
they just went in on me saying like oh
why you are doing this to your hair you
know you're not a real black person blah
blah blah and even with the rap video
like who's whose whose mother is this do
you read it in a Nigerian accent when
you read those stuff because it sounds
WAY far
it's [__] hilarious just not too far
off topic but how YouTube's a place
where people claim to be real do you
know what I mean and yet there is never
someone who so clearly got a character
and then also a very clear personal side
yeah yeah it's it's hard to like
sometimes show it because they just see
the same same person that looks like
you're the same person yeah on and off
the YouTube website so you know like
whenever people meet me hmm and see like
I'm a lot more calm like I'm a lot more
calm and just chill and like they're
always like wow this is this is
different like screaming or jumping
about like a madman like other people
expect the same thing from me it's like
mate when I'm watching a telly I'm just
scratching my balls and eating some
[__] Christmas me I'm not [__]
screaming constantly the [__] energy
for that [__] the difference in him is
he's and try to destroy the illusion you
just go I went I'm naked I'm just a fire
and they're like you telling me this I
just wanted a picture it's a five year
old anchor I just have a picture you
going I'm just scratching my balls
I don't speak the children like that as
Santa Claus that is so not something I
don't know I'd look a bit me
children love his part the inside that I
got was I edited videos for copper 94
quite a while and I had your first
series of the Wembley thing and so I got
this insight of like all your different
states for quite a while you know Neil
state like Neil come back from shooting
he'd be like
there was a lot of energy drinks needed
in and you see like this sort of you're
you're pumped for some stuff and then
the other stuff you're just totally
chillin and yet when you watch your
YouTube video it's like three minutes of
compressed stuff I think people don't
realize miss sorry just keep going I was
just gonna go down the route of you've
got plenty of time
that's a video yeah live stream did you
we how conscious of you like when did
you suddenly become conscious of your
character like in it because when you're
a teenager you're less conscious of it
like it's a bit more fluid now you seem
a bit more conscious of it than maybe
you were before yeah yeah now I realize
like you know the curtain I guess need
to be on YouTube to to be entertaining
yeah it's like if I'm just my normal
self all the time it'll be boring I mean
to a certain extent I probably say yeah
like more than of us I just want to make
that yeah I'd say Joe though Joella is
pretty much the same way he's no
incentive guy is the most on the like
the realest person the few people were
like watch your well on Jimmy Corrigan
you know it's all an act I went he will
fight him I talked him down off the
ledge after the last Wembley come he's
good he won he wanted a fight Jamie
Carragher
top of the hill I was like meeh meeh
don't do it if I'm not there for [__]
sake Jamie Carragher will kill you yeah
anyway Joe was up for it I've got that
he still is I know that don't ya yeah
but yeah most people on those same
Layton with me Brian true Joe it's not
the same [__] person like there's a
point where when the cameras are on you
don't want to be a bore and couldn't you
don't want to just sit and scratch
yourself any crisps like I'm saying
also maybe though that's part of it is
like actually if you have the same
character constantly you are going to be
a pretty boring person and in the end
you're gonna run out of stuff so if you
show more than one aspect
of your personality you're gonna be able
to well aside in different situations
people act differently men when work
together wolf footmen chop we're all
lads but then when you one-on-one with
the last say yeah yeah exactly
sort yourself out a bit determine the
terms have you ever been in that
situation where you're sort of like yeah
so I think we're gonna and then she
suddenly like so that time when you said
this thing on YouTube she replied I
thought his numbers blocked Smosh or bus
girls get in touch me do it do what I
would do just go for it alright now the
thing is I try not to mess with like
YouTube girls yeah because I feel like a
cube backfire whereas if you make some
girls who aren't youtubers it's just
like they're not in your space so they
can't do a video reaction to your sex
it's drama and they don't end up with
drama
oh sure by the way so he would love that
with this pen and pilot right now Jodie
puss-ass going on brilliant penetration
[Music]
interesting cuz obviously certain levels
of fame sort of calm certain levels of
trust you know I mean like you are
essentially you're living a Drake album
you can pick which one what take care
yeah wish I miss you baby yeah
to the beginning it's clear that this
wasn't their ideal digi oh these
packages we have you're gonna throw one
of these in your mouth and then throw it
back up yeah yeah I just [__] you I
don't know I'm saying in school in
school like I've seen early videos of
you yeah yeah
it's clear you [__] changed okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so now I have I have
like um my parents wanted me to like I
said be a lawyer or doctor or to do one
of those high-level paid jobs lower paid
than what you're on now now bankers and
lawyers watching you being like this
YouTube is here limited company yeah
yeah literally like it's it's crazy like
the the change of life well everyone
changes but you've just changed a [__]
on me yeah was there a day where you
woke up where you remember that moment
where you're like ah I'm gonna be this
person or was it more of a gradual thing
I think it's always been a gradual thing
it's never I've never it's never just
happened yeah it's always like for me
I've always enjoyed doing YouTube I
always like back in the day when no one
made any [__] money and it was just a
cool thing to do like it was a community
like yeah especially FIFA that was like
I'd go on the forums and [__] and I'd
post my videos on there and it'd be a
mini community of us just you know
showing each other's goals wings in
order and all that and playing like sick
music background
see it was like I enjoyed it way more
than school at the time because in
schools I've said this before I was
quite introverted so I didn't really
like talking to anyone or going out like
I've never seen anyone go from that oh
you like the [__] complete opposite
[Music]
but to be fair you did that else at a
time where you are most likely to take
that trip you know I mean this is still
you're still in the Mar your life where
you're learning well it's not Alex 15:25
that ten years is like the most you
probably ever change your life and
you've just done a few on that but you
know like with the YouTube thing do you
think too many people are getting into
it for the the wrong reasons now because
you read it because of a passion yeah
whereas now if it like I'll just make
some [__] noise how you can tell like
you know the people who lasts the
longest obviously care about you know
what what they do and what they post
it's not about the money for them it's
just about what it would be doing it
anyway that's it exactly so it doesn't
matter so like you know if you were
doing it just for the money and let's
say you became rich in like a year or
two then you just [__] off wouldn't you
so like for me I've always enjoyed doing
it like it's always been the coolest
thing to do yeah like I mean obviously
everyone has those moments where it's
just like on me ask but once for me once
you're in YouTube you can't go it's just
it's like an additional seven for me
it's like it's like it's a closest thing
I've ever experienced to it well
actually there was a few years there but
and I thought it's the closest thing
about to a healthy addiction yeah where
you just want to keep getting better
getting better again
like for me like this is a big moment
for me like having a big podcast things
like that like and I want to keep on
improve and improving all the time what
is it but you don't want to get studio
man
that's my philosophy
like what drives you at this point
because what drives me like my goal is
there a million subscribers I've talked
about it on the podcast once you've got
the point where you've completed YouTube
to most people what still is the
something that still drives it is that
just getting more money or ISM the more
to it no I mean like money-wise I'm good
like [__] like for me like money that
was never really the thing the main
thing for me for me it was um I know I
guess getting bigger to get girls last
week and he was like a start-up gonna
get girls I mean that's what men or
driven I got the gym cuz I don't want to
look like well actually I do look quite
but I want to look a bit better than
what I do
let's buy it I'm here I'm walking fish
so I suppose every guy let a lot of
people will go into any industry to sort
of progress themselves like it's Jo you
know for you it's no different your
parents are did they ever express being
a little bit disappointed that they were
sort of that you weren't doing the
lawyer path like was that what I mean
when I uh when I like essentially failed
my a s as well may I [__] it sucks I was
in Portugal at the time we had an
apartment and I was on the toilet
a my tutor said me my grades I like to
use the [__] was it C D F in you
every little bit of [__] straightest
drained out and I was like yo and
litterers in the toilet for like two
hours to the point where my parents are
like yo you're right you didn't want to
come out I didn't want to tell them to
tell them because I was like [__] am I
gonna tell them awful
so how did you tell them so I I was just
like
- two hours up the courage and the best
reaction ever
the kitchen door my dad with a crayon I
was so like I'm sorry and when you think
about what you've turned these
[Music]
[__] what what I've heard you do you
bought them Houston yeah yeah instantly
just yeah I bought the house I lived in
yeah and I kicked them out grateful I
think that's like that's the dream in it
for that's the best thing like and then
of all the debts and everything like
lychee lights absolute great thing so at
what point would you say things started
getting better with women what when did
that happen
um was that with the Geordie girl Shauna
shallow short of myself it's very nicely
she's good loss yeah I'd say uh mmm I
think around the period when my music
started kicking off really yeah yeah the
FIFA stuff was cool but I had two
extremely like heavily male audience
yeah if that makes sense so once I
started doing music
it's nice didn't start to see more girls
coming towards me and then seidman as
well increase yeah because they've all
got like a little bit more like
specially like Simon and those guys have
all got that predominantly Simon like
yes and worship that couldn't is style
of videos yeah like I said to mine
where's me I'm just [__] food yeah
he's nice he's nice he's nice yeah
that's what yeah Simon match that was
would you cool it with the Smasher pause
I was like no one in the sideburn could
exactly even collection kill freeze
you're late you [__] us just doing our
assignment during that yeah Toby there's
no way gee what was the reason why
they're not in the side man I was not
just so the way it happened I was just
the way it happened like it was just
because we're all playing GTA al oh yeah
and we were just two guys that play GTA
all the time right how callous was too
busy playing at all and Kyle freezy was
too busy just [__] having a good time
dude I love him and he listens for this
[__] yeah trust me he can show you the
best time genuinely one of the nicest
guys yeah yeah he doesn't eat just for
him he just loves living life yeah it's
just like he's been troubling is the
kind of guy that for him you look at him
you think you must be grateful for every
day just keep going
you've been traveling recently did you
do to her you went to a prison or summat
yeah yeah so what's a prison to try and
inspire some was that in this country
because I know yeah yeah yeah it was um
[__] where is it now oh my god
it was it was down south everywhere so
London no no no it's like downtown very
tough like shops ourselves like on the
coast
no no no it was a young offenders prison
everyone I was there was leaving this
year but yeah so it wasn't like serial
killers and Peter well I mean you know I
mean I mean not people people that had
killed people but like it was like not
again and again and again no no it's not
I would see like it's it's it's horrible
I you know when when you hear about like
some of the stories that they like the
things that they've done and all that
but you know there's always another side
to it like a
you film some of this did you know I
wanted to so much but they won't let me
I think that would have it's a shame
because I think it would have been good
to say like the serious side of you yeah
the message that you're trying new
exactly exactly I think also though
maybe it says something more about you
that you even though you didn't have to
we've all seen yeah I mean that's the
point is so so and was that you who sort
of set up but did someone come to you
and kind of say you knows all these guys
who watch your videos every day you know
watch my videos I think perfect no no no
I mean one of them had heard of my
videos but uh no I I got here up I know
just like yo do you want to do this and
I was like [__] yeah because you you've
lived a life that most people would
think isn't possible yeah so you're a
good person to be able to talk to these
people who feel like there isn't any
hope so actually me if you get your
[__] [__] together one day you could
be he not on YouTube reading I think it
is it's good to spread that message to
like people who feel like that's just me
[__] hopeless all I can do is be in a
gang or whatever you know I mean yeah
and that's the thing a lot of them feel
like that's the only thing they can do
like they're stuck in this circle where
they can't get out like they can't try
this become a normal citizen where do
you think your belief came from
originally
was I mean like you obviously had to to
believe in yourself like when you first
took the jump to did like say are I [__]
school I'm gonna give you to a real go
you must have had some belief inside you
from some idea is that your self belief
or do you think that's being put there
by people around here um I think a bit
both like my friends definitely helped
people like Simon and my Josh like and
even early early days like Phil Pato
boss a boy all those guys on our I your
shadow all nine right for an alleged
yeah I love him I love them and
literally like all those guys that we
helped
my my confidence yeah at the beginning
and I guess I did have a belief in
myself as well because like for me I was
kind of like it was getting to a point
where I just enjoyed doing it like I had
people you know [__] hate why dude
why did they were just like oh just such
a [__] [__] just get off the [__]
screen Lord
I [__] hate your content is [__]
wank I hope you kill yourself just find
the news on Amazon and just my first
week on YouTube was I hope your mother
dies of cancer
lovely message I think I remember you
saying but now your friends best from
which you mangy forever one thing I do
remember is when you were going through
the transition of just uploading goals
and your skills yes to being the
personality who brings fever to life yes
you said there was a fella who you were
sorry you can put that you can have that
for free for your website your
personality that brings FIFA to life you
did hello just cut this is [__] dog
[__] all the time
I'm spending more and more money you
said that there was a youtuber who I
actually went and watched after you said
this called
doctor disrespect ah that guy when you
said when I watched him I was like
alright I understand why yes but yeah
yeah you to peers if you watch old
doctor disrespect videos you can
definitely see like resemblances of him
and me how much he exaggerated things
yeah yeah how ridiculous he was but then
he was just serious every time
he never broke character in the grace
youtuber one of me favorites is what
he's talking into a mirror and he's like
talking to himself yeah and he's like
doctor disrespect like he saw in this
character he what he ended up getting a
job working on
and I was such a such a shame night like
he had to leave the YouTube to do this
job he's come back into it now yeah yeah
yeah I see slowly coming back into
things but yeah and I use a huge
inspiration so you kind of started what
I like to call the FIFA boom because I
missed that bit of annoying I missed out
on that I saw I started right after
everyone got like all those subscribers
for doing it the hard way I miss out on
the bus there was a snip bit on my
youtube videos every YouTube would just
lose 5 seconds it's almost like I
started and then fifa coins sort of and
[__] she was so loud Spence on and
Spencer was saying some people made
millions from or million of fifa coins
yeah are you in that family that lucky
fortunate family I'm not you know I made
enough to buy Lambo but you never seem
to promote it as much as you make
people's dead I'm not that rich of it I
just bought a lamp now it's just chillin
in my garage and if you need someone to
sell it it's on sale yeah it's not a
yeah I need to like midlife crisis
offers below I mean I'm not midlife yet
so you say you're ahead of everyone else
I look at it I mean I look younger
anyway what I found interesting and that
sort of leads on from your point the
other day was you started watching some
of your old videos back and you're sort
of cringing at some of your own
decisions
oh yeah you did a reaction to the
Eurogamer monopod that caused so many
waves in the industry at the time I mean
so a young kid being a [__]
what about the thing like at that point
I didn't know any better
yeah I like YouTube was so what we 18
what he Daniel Dan I was 1998
but even then unforgivable it's may I
invite I was doing probably just as bad
if not worse than that just there wasn't
a [__] camera
you know LEM says and you were playing a
character you it wasn't me like there's
no way out go to Gaza Maya and do that
crazy you said you're a [__] virgin
at the time very confident for a virgin
my all right now whenever the cameras on
me like it just switches me up and I'm
able to just like come into my own if
it's also confidence that only a virgin
could have sex and I'm not saying that's
in Kedah stores you know I mean about
that like virgins are like yeah [__]
oral sex
when I'm watching out there's no way I
would have thought here's a bloke who's
never [__] had said I be completely
honest I I was one of those people at
the time I was like I [__] hate this
[__] cringe and at the same time I
remind you like some of those girls in
the video and I remember just being that
oh my god like that so one of them tried
to make a career of it anyway try being
the operative word
what I found difficult at the time was
that there were some people who were
genuinely offended that by um they were
put down from the fact that they people
are you're just trying to jump on his
big figures and the fact is that both
sides are kind of right like you're a
young guy and you'll do what you want
but at the same time there are women out
there who don't want that sort of thing
down yeah yeah and so and now you're an
older guy you sort of have that
experience and you can relate to people
in it yeah and I know now what to do it
wouldn't be the same because obviously
it's like it's like Borat try to do that
character again like everyone knows who
the [__] is and it wouldn't be able to
Lowell anyone into a false sense it was
a place full of people who were all
pretending to be real people so the fact
that you're doing a character at that
time is a little bit against the trend
you know I mean yeah there are loads of
guys well hey guys just having a great
day okay we'll film yourself taking a
[__] then but you were out there sort of
doing a character and I guess there are
some people that got that some people
who thought cool I can cash in on that
and some
like you who are like what I know where
I'm going yeah did you know where you
were going like did you know where that
was going to end up nope
I had no idea I was just making videos
yeah I was just doing what the people
wanted because I did videos like that
before to just general people in the
public and people loved it and I was
just like I think it's like with YouTube
sometimes it can you just times you can
think that's the only audience in the
world yeah
whereas there's actually like hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of millions of
people out there so to just do a video
and just be like oh I mean it's good for
this bubble market like it's good for
everyone yeah yeah so he what that is
not the video a man makes when he's
thinking about the long term plan
oh dude it [__] me up like a mob
opportunities I've lost because of that
is just tremendous like I don't Walter I
guess get back to state where you know
I'm comfortable again polite yeah people
wouldn't recover from something like we
know the thing like there's some
youtubers out they don't have to sell
who there's some youtubers out there
who've done bad [__] and it's never come
back well yeah Thapa loves yeah [__]
ruined surprisingly I actually know
other people who were with him and they
say he's a lovely guy but people made
bad decisions and you live by the sword
and die by the sword it doesn't change
what you said or what you did you know
it but at the same time you were a young
guy and use I'm not saying you need to
repent or anything but when you watch
your back you can what you're watching
what I like about it is how regretful he
was throughout the whole video I really
respected up but then I also respect
that the YouTube part made respected
when he when should have this left on my
[__] channel 3 million views I could
have employment you know I do like that
and why I because I obviously subscribe
Church and I'm I like the way that you
use the same like energy that you use
towards that sort of stuff towards the
racism and those sort of people and I
thought one of your most not say
down a deep root but one of your most
poignant videos or wanting in my series
series of poignant videos was about
racism and those people who were racist
reaction to that as a black man or as a
young black man was actually it was
deeper than a lot of other like there
are those people out there doing charity
work who were like oh you reach way more
people than we could we could reach in
you know the whole year of talking to
people about this you know I think there
was like a space of maybe two or three
weeks where you were reacting to what
other people had said online stuff
you've been saying some stuff you found
and your reaction and how you felt I
can't remember the exact video but I
mean the thing is like you know like for
me like someone is racist to me like I'm
at the point where I just don't care
like well you said that you were at a
school where you were one of the only
two blocks yeah yeah so I'm assuming
you've probably dealt with that for a
hell of a lifetime like I've you know
like I've had situations where I've been
bullied because I'm people you know I've
been black it's just it's just one of
those things like have you experienced a
different kind of racism us you've
gotten successful and rich and that way
I don't know Raheem Sterling racism
maybe I don't know yeah it's like it
changes from he has a regular black head
to you as a rich black kid is it did
people treat you differently or um I
feel like um whenever people meet me and
they don't know who I am they would
treat me completely different to then
someone who has met me I mean who knows
of me yeah yeah I feel like a lot of
time because more and more people start
to know who I am I'm not really getting
to see the real person that I'm talking
to yeah that makes sense which is
ashamed because like I don't want people
to always to put me on this pedal stool
right I want them to treat me like a
normal guy like a lot of time like I did
some filming and when the guys were
packing up I helped and they're like
what are you doing yeah I'm I'm just
hoping I like and they're like that's
generally amazing I never help
I do is you'll go over and you'll take
the stuff out the boxes he's actually
actively trying to stop us from Brian's
just eating it like it's terrible I am
an [__] yeah yeah but that's such an
exclusive thing that only really you and
a couple of guys have the experience of
so there's very few people you can share
that experience with well you are
surrounded by other people you know
there are other rappers that may be your
wave a couple of like the sidemen the
YouTube guys who know what that
experience like so I guess it's
important to keep those guys around you
at the same time the thing they they
keep me grounded like in a weird way
because they're all up with you in that
exactly like so many times you know I
could easily just lost my way interests
that's the thing you don't want people
who are just yes yes man around you
because you'll then think you're the
[__] and then you'll treat people like
[__]
have you ever do you think you've ever
been in that situation where you have
had yes men around you yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah I've maybe a few people yeah
who've gassed me up and who've made me
think oh [__] out of all of the of all
of the side men who is this castithan
man who was it out of all of them who's
the most likely to poly and gore
JJ maybe being a bellend like is anyone
who would say that's it all of them yeah
and he's all the same with each other
yeah yeah yeah call someone out if the
shine [__] it's just how is that so out
of all of them who'd since becoming big
and creating these videos mmm
who would you say is impressed you like
the more so like not that they're not
all great I know you probably read them
all but I'm just meaning like as anyone
who's sort of surprised here in your
latest know level I never expected him
to go on and do this I'll do that I'll
change as much as he has like there's
anyone who's really grown a lot um I'd
say I want to say a few people why I
tell you first of all Simon yeah I'd say
Simon like from where we started like
you know like him helping me out doing
videos to why he has where he is now
it's just tremendous like he's
he's so hard-working like me he actually
I've got to be honest he inspires me
like oh yeah yeah the start of the year
I was like thinking 2017 and I'm not
[__] around anymore and like I looked
at his channel and I'm like that
[__] as a machine yeah he's mash
is it like it goes so well like anxious
constantly just like you know thinking
okay what what video can I do next or
you know how can we build the side
membrane how can we do this how you
don't do that and yeah he's always on it
so he's done really well Josh he's also
done really well but the thing is Josh
she's more of a guy behind the scenes
yeah so that comes across behind the
scenes he just supports the side man
so so so much we choke [__] Narborough
like is that like the granddaddy well
without Josh like Seidman would crumble
most of the guys crumble but like Josh
especially like he is the guy who just
you know make [__] happen in like he I
guess put order and stability and
everything and it's good up like a
family [__] cuz I've ever everyone in
the Seidman like plays their part yeah
I'll feel a bit like that cuz when I
first come into YouTube it was totally
by accident I mean a rant video and it
took off and then I thought let's do a
few more of these and see what the [__]
happens yeah but since meeting Lauren's
and having someone who I can ring up and
go yeah is this a good video as a bad
video and just talk do you saw it really
helps sometimes he cause you do not
upload that do not do do not do that it
just it makes you feel I can I thought
about that and I thought it must be
better having a bit of a family guy cuz
he's like my brother now on yes general
I mean yeah it's good other it's so
important it's so important and yeah I'm
just but you've had some good [__]
nights over those like you know what no
really no I'm kidding oh [__] now for
like you know surprisingly it's it's the
Simon on the guys are probably with the
most really know they're all because
that's such work I was like they're
everywhere
if I want to work I'd kill the Seidman
if I want to party at sea cow [__]
going let's go home
mate you've got me number a rung on the
other way let's go but I guess it's also
difficult to go out with any FIFA base
youtubers because you could be in a club
or a bar at any time and they go
20k just serious yeah yeah Vic would I
think one day is like literally traveled
back from we win some country and he's
traveled all the way back just to patch
us for no not for I know I seduced a
showing video and then come all the way
back you can tell these we got a
solution for that video thing you can
carry to be like you guys are like you
know Oh watch where you win what's he
look for iron upper it was eyeing up
yeah I an upper he flew back early to do
certain videos like sorry sorry I've got
some video submit yeah it's fine to
worry about but big again it's he's so
hot wife that's why exactly he's just
again always on it like he's a machine
like do it most of the guys in the cyber
not just machines would you say are you
in terms of hard workers lower the lads
is the one that sort of like stands out
like who's like of hardest worker
hardest worker hmm I'd say it's between
I'd say between vacant Simon yeah yeah
I'd say but when you're making a video
do you just like wait for an idea a
company or just other people help you or
or do you like right cuz I'll write [__]
down yes sir I write I write down this
well I have notes on my on my same yeah
and I'll let you just write down ideas
and then I'm just like okay let me work
on this and like
it's someone else who's been consistent
yeah yeah he's done he's I'm a
firefighter you know we got the red man
so I'm not along after that you sort of
but you've got any music musics a huge
passion yeah yeah mmm how is that
different than YouTube um so with new
music me it's kind of similar but it's
just I guess the approach can is kind of
different and I don't know like write
lyrics down on your phone yeah yeah all
right yeah I have like several lyrics
just on my phone constantly like a
picture was so nice - oh I can give you
I can give you some somebody some
exclusive it's not even joking as well
you know like you know like track with a
blackberry I'm thinking well yeah yeah
yeah you know it's just like yeah yeah
yeah of course one I'd like to win
I am I don't know I want to play the
beat you can do yeah you better yeah
anything
okay all right so this is this is
something this is just like nature ska
thing all right
no no you must have Roby
I want just overall be instrumental okay
all right guys ready all right come on
yo ah got a fat chick twerking call it
Royal Rumble
smoking weed [__] poppin still my money
humble serf a sausage in her face like
William penny hana cuz she butts my
stick last year 64 Impala better to you
to to me manager Bruce Lee mo kio Cheon
I live here profusely like Godzilla I'm
out here full-blown killer [__]
I'm out here go all [__] [__]
like cougar that dick well I got any
like favorite artists I've inspired you
um I'd say like people like DMX off yeah
that's [__] mad you said he I
literally sat in the back of our cab on
the way here was like originally it came
out of my eye I was trying to think we
were thinking of questions for you and
it came out of my mouth it sounded
insulting I was like if you were a real
rapper who would you he says DMX and
then Jordie was like don't ask it you
would be like DMX have you ever seen
that documentary from the Rockefeller
tour with like jay-z and they were with
some with so there's basically two to
set two says a rapper's gone on tour
right there was an amazing documentary
from 1999 when Rockefeller gone tour and
they've got DMX what I loved about DMX
is the way rot was like from the heart
it was raw as [__] like who we be it was
like the realest [__] type of rap and
you get with it's a shame what happened
to him like I don't know if you've seen
him lately
yeah he's [__] off of the drug so yeah
he's absolutely
it's a beautiful she could still be an
ink wasn't but he seems like a racist he
he just talks and I could listen him
talk over a like a bit that is lately
rapping like it
doesn't yeah rhyming Wow
that's what 21 savages like yeah I was
here yeah the way he just taught easy
talks but like he got [__] up over
drugs and to be fair like how have you
stayed like to be honest I'm gonna press
try that like cuz really I can tell
you're not that type of dude no I don't
do any drugs and only drug ideas weed
but I've said this like I'm pregnant all
oh yeah yeah my mom would have like then
she really would go botch it's like I'm
doing it everyday it's not like get high
every time all right I do it maybe like
maybe every six months we've both we've
both admitted to this it's also if you
go to America you go to the states you
realize the difference in perception of
weed in the UK oh my god you can get for
free then yeah it's so easy right and
that's but that completely changed the
way you're approaching how often would
you say especially when you first became
pretty big have you been approached with
or do you want this to on that you go to
you like I guarantee you every hotel you
go to there will be a man who can get
you whatever you do and avoids I have a
good like strong will because I didn't
wrong relationship with local drug
dealers you don't realize until you know
the right people like holy everyone's on
[__] cork like you until it take oh
yeah you talk of the right people to say
he's on it he's on it she's on it and
everyone's on it if you go sit in hotels
it's certain youtubers yeah we've all
seen YouTube produces but then also with
the music side of things it's partly
different for you because you are gonna
need a bit more help to produce a track
than you are to just be able to go and
sit in front of a web I'm not reducing
it but to go and sit in front of a
webcam and be like right here's what I'm
gonna say you need a bit more help
producing a professional sound new
trailer you need someone to master it
yes yes
that's why sway helps me out with all of
that yeah I remember saying sway and
this I was [__] me I must have been I
was 16 and I was at a unique thing and
Newcastle went Dizzee Rascal released
boy in the corner and I was front row
and sway was his warmup I was there and
I'm loving like this kids [__] greats
way I like him I'm gonna [__] get his
own and now like he's helping you he's
gone under yeah he's gone on has he
helped you a lot yeah yeah 100 say yeah
100% what's he like as a bloke
these are dude he's so knowledgeable
like dude he could talk for it cuz I've
noticed that is you've improved a lot
would you put that down baby with sway
has helped me tremendously yeah like
he's such a good father figure yeah and
yeah and he's just like like guidance
wise helps me so much like putting me in
the right direction like he's always
commenced me saying like well play with
what you've done on YouTube and you're
not going into drugs and all that and
essentially like he's just been the best
guy for me when it comes to the music it
was like it was it for you to break into
the music industry's I know that there's
a lot of people also who they see
YouTube in their life yeah yeah I mean
you're a youtuber man and you know you
weren't as the same rapper you were when
you first start yeah yeah you think it's
like when I first I was just a loud guy
yeah it was guest great numbers but uh
yeah nowadays like I'm starting to make
actual music not even prove that I'm not
even are no rap music like ugly
listening we [__] over a decade that
you've improved so much do you feel that
yourself like your own progression yeah
yeah yeah why does that I like comparing
like the stuff I've got coming up this
year too
mmm obviously like Lamborghini and all
that those type of songs and even like
the what the rap battles I used to do
with Randolph like yeah I can just see
like but it's as if people expect you to
[__] come out the gate and be nice
just a whoa yeah it's like if you listen
to like Eminem's early [__] like he
wasn't the lyricist years now
so he sounds like a different [__]
person Cory the finished article on your
first album kendrick lamar's mixtapes
are very different to Kendrick Lamar's
yes big his mixtapes are full of sounds
where it's like it's not actually his
yeah yeah you're the thing that happened
for you was you didn't you just didn't
come up on you look like you were never
quite so that's that's the annoying
thing while on the ground was publicized
mainstream straight off how many people
were there any people who you met who
was sort of openly disrespectful to the
the process that you've been on or did
you hear about people who openly I'm not
asking you to name them but there are
obviously getting people who disparage
what you do well yeah I like those
people in the music industry that I hate
why do like they you know that's just
like just like you've got YouTube [__]
off stay in your box in LA like you
don't need to do this music stuff and
for me it's like it's just been a
passion that's ridiculous Jamie Foxx can
he can act well why should we limit him
if he didn't do all of those great
things you never would have seen him
play it was at Rachel's we would never
see in some of the great things he's
like Django and yeah why would we tell
limits someone general I mean it's just
I think some people tell you let me
guess I mean there are gonna be people
are gonna tell you to limit yourself
because maybe there are people who are
worried about you over stretching
yourself or not making as much money
from their thing because of that you
know yeah yeah of course it's threatened
in that sense yeah yeah I mean
competition is always like a big thing
when it comes to those type of talks
yeah it's just people feel competition
people just fear people changing or
doing doing more than better in this
yeah yeah well it's like a crab and a
bucket mentality I know when I first
started and it's the small time as I am
comparing what you're on in Newcastle
when I started is this fine who's just
getting a little bit of no right in all
these voices getting hurt hmm a few are
the local Twitter accounts and Facebook
accounts they [__] hear that doesn't
and I can only imagine on the scale that
you [__] so far yeah of course but I
mean
like I said I just I don't give a [__]
those guys because I don't know no no
that's like I've never done any of this
[__] for validation like never like for
me it's always just been about me and
like what I want to do your opinion I
think has to matter the most
that's it has to if you're not happy
with yourself then you can't make anyone
else happy it's I had a question last
week I was talking to someone about they
were saying do you ever worry about the
comments and in that and I'm like well
my opinion of what is good and what
isn't good has got me this far
yeah I'm gonna trust a friend and until
that proves me wrong I'm gonna keep
going and it's got us this far so let's
keep going you have branched out into a
lot of things movies yes you did lead in
America Ellen Casper
how'd you feel about that yeah it was
cool it was it was cool thing to do
like for me I always like trying stuff
so I tried the movie thing and a lot of
people really enjoyed my acting they
were like I'm really surprised surprised
yeah like how I actually did alright
YouTube is like acting in a way of the
words I century yeah used to be in front
of the camera
I mean I'm I think a big good actor I
would I would like to do wolf of Wall
Street or you do act well I'll give you
that like there are times where yeah
that's a direct last week and saw yeah
but then what I find interesting was
obviously what I was reminded of when
you made that video about the way that
people were illegally downloading it was
yeah at the very similar time we would
only shoot with Public Enemy and we had
like a quiet chat with Chuck D
afterwards and he was saying what most
people don't realize is I can't stop
touring like I can't stop working
because there are so many people that
rely on me for that work and I think
there was a similar vibe to what you
were saying about these people don't
like it's difficult for them to make
another film if they find out that
everyone's gonna pirate this previous
film yeah yeah so it's icy to the point
where we're not gonna make a sequel
really yeah that's a shame though yeah
shame I mean like it's just how it is
like executives throw in their toys out
the pram no or is that literally use
people being because it still got
legally downloaded quite a lot yeah yeah
that's I think it's toys at the problem
yeah yeah yeah will you do another film
though what do you try yeah I mean you
do I seem as passionate about that as
music though no I'd say so you think is
my passion yeah maybe the future is go
back into acting but right now yeah I'm
really focused on the music music you
got you got more things planned yeah
yeah yeah yeah but just keeping it
there's something coming you come here
for insight include live shows those
sort of things
sorry they're gonna be like live shows
have you enjoy your life performing do
you enjoy I love it
[__] love I was shocked at home like
how far you call it you've imagined he's
off the deep end this could like once
he's in he's gone for it dude you sure
you don't do drugs by the way I just I
just [__] love it so much man I just
gay just get in the moment and just I
lose myself
you love the crowd come on boy that's
why I'm always jumping in like my
bodyguard so he's going [__] nuts
going like for [__] sake stop jumping
in the crowd it's hard to tell you I
won't tolerate that I do do some
bodyguard extra work so just I'm always
working if you mount a GoPro that's a
Youtube subscriber Sam you obviously you
know you're punched out in their movies
and you've done so many things you've
also done quite a lot with celebrities
in general yeah yeah I was jealous I've
never been jealous as much before but
you did a video with Conor McGregor yeah
yeah such a cool guy what was it like
it's just a good luck I've never played
this before
ninja no sorry I was just i up is
so ya know I like I made sure I try to
beam the second round but I and you done
stuff with the rock as well he's again
so charismatic like he's just oozes with
like he's got a youtube channel as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's just smashing
it splashing it is there any youtubers
you've met where you're being like I've
never [__] do it out with I couldn't
again well I mean this one Barry alright
[Laughter]
yeah go for it
is there any to do this because of who I
am I don't really get [__] yeah because
they know it's not worth they know it's
worth being cool to me because of what
they can get out of it yeah
the mug life that whoever runs the mutt
life is clearly a smart dude like for
Conor McGregor's sick because he he went
and got the best people straight like he
knew exactly how to promote the channel
and he knew the new they know what
they're doing over there I was a great
impressed he's ahead of the game like on
the MMA side of things cuz he's put no
videos of put like training on that and
like I'm looking at UFC fighters they're
all struggling to get sponsorships yeah
yeah he's he saw had it marketing-wise
he is yeah yeah do you think it to this
point you sort of think about Thursday's
where you would have to shoot edit and
do and put everything together and kind
of see how far you've come in that sense
yeah yeah one who sent like seem from
the beginning like how I would just ah
dude I remember when I had to take my
computer my whole computer take all the
way downstairs to record a video and
then I'll take all the way back upstairs
to edit and rebuild it yeah yeah
rebuilding everything like I told to
take the monitors and everything [__]
you still have that computer in the
[__] museum one day may I just for
the internet explorer history animal
porn
what anyone to do like what I'm
impressed by is my with most young to
YouTube is it's not only like the fact
you're doing v4 videos you're also
editing your own videos and your edits
were different to many else's edits yeah
yeah yeah it's yeah I think again I just
got inspiration from a load of other
youtubers that I watch a lot of YouTube
so I would I guess see what was good
from their videos what was bad and then
I just try and work my own I guess put
your own spin on my own spin on yeah and
then just go ham I think a lot of
creative people they look at the best
and then they take from it and then
think how would I do
well yeah rather than just taking and
copying yeah yeah I don't like that
that's yet so that don't for me that
doesn't work for me I just it just
doesn't I think that we are running out
of creative people on YouTube it's no
there's several creative youtubers out
there it's just you better lost him in a
say is that the loss of the CEO people
just call of stuff [__] it everything
yeah I mean you find a channel you're
like oh my god this is really good
there's something quite rewarding about
people but you've evolved in all those
of a vault but there's a few out there
who they just don't seem to be evolving
yeah yeah again because they just I
guess don't push push themselves to do
stuff outside the box it's just like our
to stay in my box yeah stay in my lane
and just because you've you've made an
unbelievable amount of people have an
income oh like you've made more jobs
than Steve Jobs made she was like yeah I
remember chaos I was on his channel need
more views for him and I mean like it's
you you've really helped a lot of people
like you're helping me right now but
you've helped the [__] ton of people
yeah is there anyone you have a thing
but I know there's one lad we all know
we know the story but is anyone engaged
what George getting the cube I'm
actually boys are asses what really
buffle me about that was when he he took
so long
apologize after being a late yeah yeah
and then when he did he did it in the
weirdest [__] voice I've ever heard
in our dude that was fun even run the
kitchen as a meme what's going on
because he didn't always talk like that
yeah so you just used to rub up and be
like alright may as fancy shooting a few
videos for glitches put this up in your
house usual situation to be how you had
do you generally worry about the
intentions of people who come into your
life of what are you bit like guard up
because you understand that people might
not want to just be your mate for like
regular people on the street if someone
wants a beer mate it's for no other
reason than they like the crack cheering
I mean whereas with you you've got a bit
more to think about
um I'm into a sterling sin yes but like
for me I just I just don't care you
don't give a yeah I'm just like if I
even the to a sin a sin with women like
you know I know some girls are with me
just because I'm case I but then I just
use that to get a bang and then P school
same thing shark a shark in that sense
like if someone's trying to get with you
for give me the Austin why am I gonna
reject it I'll take it and then you look
up bunch I'll say yeah yeah yeah and so
on you know gives me a house of right
intentions then I'll show them the
respect that
it's like Sean uh for example the
girlfriend that you once had she was the
last girl run you sort of publicly and
she was obviously there for the right
reasons yeah yeah good lass yeah and you
give other respect she's I'm still cool
with her now yeah yeah like she's like a
great friend to me so brilliant just
some extent to be a YouTube girlfriend
you have to have a great amount of
understanding of what it is to be on
YouTube and I carry her aspect anyone
who date's you anyone who date's you or
anyone
our understanding of that you know I
mean and like if you don't essentially
like maybe you're just not equipped for
that exactly yeah and some some girls on
becoming because like some of them don't
want to be in the limelight and the yeah
yeah it's not every five minutes for a
four for me I kind of like I kind of was
I guess half half but I kind of wish I
didn't Shoshana and and spotlight like I
feel like it um it's not the best it's
not the best thing to just popular size
like this is my girlfriend this is my
god yes then they scrutinize you do you
think you judge you as well and a lot of
times it's not fair
like I remember back in the day when
Shauna would just wouldn't want to be in
a video because she was scared of what
people were saying about or she didn't
want to take an Instagram photo because
of what people would say about it like
they'll just be like oh like oh you look
too skinny or oh you should eat more
well there's a bunch of [__]
[__] I'll say yeah yeah yeah so
like I mean do you think if you had
someone who like in future you could
became really serious or if you'd be
like tonight is I'm gonna try and avoid
it as much as possible yeah yeah I mean
they defecate on the ramps like I'm
gonna let me burn and we'll know about
it so you got a girlfriend right now
[Music]
but yeah one thing I wanted to talk to
you about just this is just for me
really fun [__] everyone else brand
deals and that sponsorships and paid
videos I'm sort of getting at that stage
we have some like sponsorships and all
of that and you go and you're having to
deal with people who are so different
than me and you like youtubers have you
ever had funny experiences or dodgy
experiences with these like all guys
with money basically who are trying to
invest and get the products promoted but
like they don't get people like me and
you where you're like yeah as me [__]
your money I'm not even gonna do dude
the brand deals I've rejected ridiculous
yeah it's like I've been offered like
six-figure deals yeah yeah
I would sell tampons for that just
anything no I know you mean yeah yeah
and then I decided it's not worth
dealing with integrity wise it doesn't
work and it's one more for my channel
and it's just I'm having meetings right
now and it's so [__] frustrating
dealing with people like the times where
you're trying to get it across we're
like I want to keep who I am and yeah
yeah the change because then why don't
they what's the other random yeah like
I've you like YouTube channels is like a
restaurant where you serve a bad meal
people are less likely to come back yeah
and then if you serve a three bad meals
they're not coming back so I'm like I
don't want to keep putting out like [__]
videos just for a couple of grand or
whatever it might be that people are
offering because then in the long run
you'll eventually find out that if you
keep your integrity and you keep doing
what you want to do yeah eventually
companies will cater to that yeah and
then pay you to just be yourself you are
and then it's easy easy peasy at that
point so yeah because since you're in
that situation like you don't you could
go through that stage exactly like
there's no point doing all these like
mini sh t deals that will just change
who you are or what your ideal video is
or what you want to do you just have to
stand firm yes stand firm do you and
then eventually everyone will get around
it like if you're getting tremendous
amount of you it's like you are then an
advertiser is gonna be like okay he was
more it's a bit annoying it's like it's
like they're actively rejecting that's
what I also respect about the rest of
the sidemen was one of the first
conversations we had we arrived at
Southampton I think we started with
Kalends do all the lads were they all a
lot and they was we were talking about
other deals and other stuff that was
coming up and they were sort of saying
we want you know we won't do any deal
without JJ that was in regards to the
worm Leacock no no well yeah but there's
a number of things we were talking about
Jeremy and some anonymity I don't really
care No
I don't send some yourself you know yeah
one thing I would you got like so many
[__] fans mind it and who they
absolutely love you like what is what is
it like when you meet these people who
like idolized you
oh it's great it's really good like you
know whenever I meet a fan like I'm
always like yeah let's take a photo and
everything and I always talk to them
like you know whatever they want to talk
about all that like I'm really like just
calm when it comes to me and people like
I I don't it's like I hate seeing people
it's not like I might say no no yeah
like the only time I get slightly bored
is if there's a lot of people yeah I
like the huge amount
I experience oh Hampton when we were on
the bus because I I've been recognized a
[__] ton but it's normally like you know
a few people here you're out it's not a
mulga me she's also funny because when
we first pulled up at Southampton
Stadium we come from the hotel and we
were in a cab and obviously everyone was
just getting cabs down off the stadium
and there are all these screaming girls
outside the cabin the windows are tinted
they thought I was care sides back and
they go it's not him and they're like oh
I got true Jordans a few of them one of
Menno so I stepped out the time people
like oh my god it's not him in the car
just drive
have you ever had any bad experiences
with the funds oh I know you I've had
one one by the experience yeah this is
in Coventry there's on a night out so
the whole day I've been me in fact Sue
and this is a dozen interior Oh today
I've been meeting fans and just you know
taking pictures here and there so I was
absolutely knackered but I wanted to go
on a night out with my friends and we
went out I forgot what the club is
called now but we went out and was a
warning Coventry yeah
what are your point find it it's pretty
well but when out got a few drinks and
you know we'll just have naked time
everyone's having an absolute ball and
then all of a sudden a few people
started coming up they recognize who I
was I know like can I have a picture so
I was like okay fine you know I take a
few pictures like I knew this was gonna
happen it's just how it is
so take a few pictures and it just kept
going like for the whole like night you
know to a point where I was just like
okay I'm done with first now so I was
like the next person that says Duke I
never throw I'm just gonna be like no I
I just wanna I just want to party
because I wasn't that I didn't have any
time to like go out and just have fun
like or just too much and just drinking
just for me when I was like I prefer
going out and London did not do
Newcastle
I love Newcastle it's me home but when I
go out a Newcastle I am like if me and
you went out with Newcastle yeah it
would be maybe worse than you probably
know yeah cuz New Castle's a goldfish
bowl yeah and the blokes they love the
football so like people in Newcastle
open glasses and you are black in a bar
in a bit much conduct well yes so then
it got to a point where another person
this dude came up to me I just like cuz
I'm a for an outside
sorry bro I've been taking photos all
day and I've been taking photos all
night as well in this club and I don't
want to take him MorphOS and he was like
dude it's one foe to take it and I was
like bro I'm sorry I really I'm just I
wanna like have some fun with my mates
like I'm sorry no and he was just like
what the [__] bro it takes like two
seconds just take a [__] phone you
came you see what he's saying but yeah
but he doesn't see the [__] day
you've I'm saying
so he's just for him he's just like he
just see me once probably in this one I
want a photo with this dude and I was
like dude so he's clearly drunk like no
one in their right mind would act like
that yeah so then I was like
like this isn't gonna happen and then he
pushed me and I was like [__] off
this house I what the [__] are you doing
like are you serious so literally he was
like just take a [__] fold me like he
was literally like proper series
sticking in my eyes so I was like you
[__] touch me one more time I'm gonna
[__] kill you unless I was about to
[__] knock him out my men were amazed
held me back though I Pro you don't want
to do this it's not we're [__]
everything yeah yeah and lychee like
they held him back as well and oh like
Jason man just it's it's no author and
then one one Isis Torian to the guy like
what the [__] you doing like leave him
alone Jesus you have to like think a lot
more before you act in general like you
know like yeah a normal kid send a dick
pic it's no [__] big deal with you
that chick could like change is that in
the wrong hands I you know yeah do you
have to think a lot before you act in
general everything a normal person could
have swung at that bloke and then it
started that's why I have a bodyguard
now yeah so whenever I go out I always
have a bodyguard next to me like and I
just none of that happens now like yeah
cool I'll take a phone and if he wants
to be a douchebag I just play the game
see how far away you can get from your
bat like to see how far you can get away
from her just be good he's the best guy
like nice one he's just done so much oh
well he's helped me out so much so some
people don't seem to understand oh is it
like people don't seem to son you're
almost need for that at that point
doesn't think I know a lobby we're gonna
be like confuses tubelight
wait what the [__] you need a bodyguard
but people forget that 15 million
[__] subscribers what is that how
many like billion views dwell exactly
like Peter how many
three yeah well it's a lot of people to
see me so like whenever someone sees me
out the blue though it's just like I
what the [__] you doing here and it's
like on insane trees I'm just getting
something to eat yeah like condoms no
[Laughter]
I'm a normal guy but I still need to do
he had a piss beforehand like you just
did yeah he does regular [__] normal
we're gonna edit that in afterwards just
to show what it's like that's the
dick-pic we're gonna release it on this
show subscribe but kanye west got away
we sent a [__] dick pic and like he's
still around
yeah yeah I mean god that's even more
shameful thought she'd be better on that
issues a little bit Tim for me I watched
her right at the end yeah the whole rayj
is a he just doesn't come across well so
in general hopefully a sex tape isn't in
your future what what is in the future
for you what sort of future for me I
don't know I'm kind of just seeing how
what where life takes me I'm I've never
really had a plan for any of this like
I've never expected to be here pull of
me like for me it's always just me just
do why I love doing and just just enjoy
life
nice what man is interesting yeah do
some emails I've got a couple of Twitter
questions yeah okay grayble from actual
fans I mean make good Twitter questions
as well you don't have to answer all of
these right what's your beef with
PewDiePie
does that realize that like just a joke
first of all I believe we both respect
each other
oh well respects each other but I feel
like there is a bit of competition as
well to a certain extent so obviously
you know we just have a few tubes and
jabs a friendly rivalry yeah I think
that's what it is like ultimately like
we are in the in a similar space and
yeah I would see like there's going to
be conflict sometimes we've just you
know anything and you know I've never
met the dude I'm sure he's a nice guy am
i should talk to his editor Oh guy
that's his videos when I was I think
heading to New York yeah it was just
yeah he was going was in New York we're
going somewhere and I hit me up saying
the same thing like eyes the beef of you
and PewDiePie Rio and I was like no I
respect the guy like I think it's just
competition yeah if anyone clips this up
and put it on their channel I will
copyright strike you just substitute put
me in there first right the true Jordi's
just saying now javis the copyright
strike thing I warned you doing that I'm
children I didn't even know like I
didn't know cuz I have a label what
could happen yeah that's the thing
my label just doesn't tell me like
what's one of my songs was playing in
this series 50 cent Oh
power power power looking great zoom
didn't [__] tell me about like this
so label knew okay fine I follow is when
people tweet tweet me your oh sure doing
this and I'm like oh [__] I am
the label just does so much [__] without
telling me which I mean it's cool what
can be annoying sometimes also though
like surely that series would want you
to know that so you can be like guys I'm
in this episode there's 15 million
people like triples the amount people
what was it like being on YouTube rewind
are yes cool fun experience yeah I've
always cool if you could start YouTube
over again what would you do differently
I probably would do porn yes yeah just
have that little stint good springboard
and just so that when I got to this
point I'd have as people would you know
like find I did porn and then is there
ever a day you hate being as famous as
you are probably has about many don't
not really it's pretty good about the
other part you could have taken that you
went to private school your parents
wanted you go down a certain path you
could legitimately be you know in a bank
right now you could be alert do you know
I mean I failed me all my dolls as she
tried to get whether I was overqualified
may feel feel sick we'd heard your music
howdy how does he feel he's handled for
him if he was to rape himself hour 10
probably do I'd be dead in a ditch right
now on me I would have known a new
almost a pride in that I mean I nearly
ended up dead in a ditch before YouTube
so it's a miracle
yeah I'm here you know a million
subscribers or maybe if that happens
we'll see what do you what do you think
about this do you pick I can I respect
yeah cool
everyone you know everyone has their
angle everyone has a way of getting and
you've been quite a big supporter of
like people taking different I like the
drama scarce and all that I fully
support like it's their way their way in
and you know it's it's you know believe
it or not it's good for the community I
mean it can be bad obviously it can be
very bad for certain people but like if
you're a pedophile it's yeah yeah well I
just think that's a general life rule I
mean that's not really like oh god if
your people don't get into that YouTube
drama they'll hate that alright what is
GOG is most favorite porn category oh
look alikes i like big asses I go for
the big ass women okay personally um I'd
say facials facials that's it there's
one woman who did make a video on
YouTube about how she she gets a man to
spunk in a cop rubs it on her face
because it is actually good for skin so
I'm doing a good deed to woman me you're
doing them a lot of favors appreciate it
keep spreading the joy but sexual
experience is the one that sticks out um
I always awkward what's good
I had anal for the first time yeah I
didn't even know it
so I was um I'm waiting paper to go how
big was he know anyway that's what you
do so the girl was like honest I like
this and I was like and literally side
by side on this bad selecting I know I
just I just went in and I was just
busting and thrusting so I was like I'm
gonna finger her while I'm doing this
thing oh yeah and while I was doing I
was like [__] where's my penis went
deeper found shouted oh my god I mean
I literally pulled out and went for
[__] sake what are you on about
Wow the fact that was she aware she was
aware I was in wow this guy goes Wow
literally she was just like it's calm
like she's done a number for I mean for
me I was like this is [__] this is
mine she's like really us most girls you
have to have a long talk before you yeah
yeah yeah it's a whole thing get the
lube and sexy and work your way in this
guy straight in I just love it
it's a lot Commodore iron in there it is
me it is a lot dryer as well yeah
[Music]
there's also that experience like I
don't if you ever seen a set Rocky's
documentary doing noisy where he was
talking about just Van Gogh's coming
along and he was like normally like you
know you you think you got a [__] girl
and she ends up [__] you how many
rows experience of you have where
they're like oh like tell me yeah wanna
go [__] you oh my god see I would I
would like you to see well great hello
don't think I'm like really aggressive
yeah when I'm like I've heard that but I
am NOT I'm like the most passionate like
love until yeah yeah you didn't seem not
gentle on smusher possible thing but
that's you - wrong yeah that's true when
we're all alone with women you know dear
what I'm gonna be like
because you're gonna get smashed okay
Unum 800 block the women women expect
caveman treatments oh yeah anything less
than that they're like actually you're
quite sensitive yeah yeah so the bottle
angry ironically live I was pretty low
for me just saying
alright that was good appreciate it's
that girl from tinder actually pregnant
someone said oh no no if you watch girls
with you this is the for faith yeah
last but not least when get ear not
Wenger India solo you and gently this
was nice hello happy Strayer day from
Australia Jordi and the other person
hello Mercedes ever been referred it was
the other hello my name is evening yeah
good and I arranged a date with a girl
at a beach and I'm 15 years old and
never been on one before a beach road
date was wondering on any tips that I
will need to make this situation or quit
to not make this situation awkward
[__] on the [__] sure that's why I
would usually say so the shore that's
next amen
sure with dreams yeah agreed if you're
gonna first ape the girl you know I mean
you need to let her know what's going
down yeah and if you [__] around a [__]
she understands sure women love that
like especially if you do a good job
the keep a guy that knows way once just
shout beforehand that Trump vibe and
then just yeah this one's entitled I
cheated on my
friend do I tell her la capitals help
hello true Jodi Lawrence and
loving the podcasts Ben listen a blob of
lime 19 years old right now my current
girlfriend is never good when you say my
current girlfriend you know they're then
gonna expire it's also the same age if
that helps your advice here call me
David
my girlfriend knows I love your podcast
2015 I got on the tinder game to see
what I was or it was all about and
breaking up with my ex-girlfriend I
match this girl called Amy what I do
notice is many men give a fake name of
Amy
there's either one girl who's actually
called Amy who's [__] all these guys
or the name Amy sounds like she's it's
the first one on the alphabet the limits
I don't think they go into a website
going names i ID match this girl she
call Amy me and Amy chatted for a few
weeks then she thought she had traveled
a couple of hours to meet me we got on
very well of course and one thing led to
another over me and Amy never dated as
such we stayed in touch in November I
met this girl at work Jesus moment when
your life story I don't know what your
problem is in February 2016 a man died
message before he had messaged me on
Facebook and we got talking again for
the first time since October she'd asked
me to meet up so of course he did I told
my girlfriend I was seeing my friends in
reading he then go this is so [__]
long however I knew what I was doing
this longer than some relationships I
thought he had genuinely mean reading
that is longer than the whole anal
chapter that happens right genuinely
he's cheating on his girlfriend this
girl called Amy is the up and down of it
what does he do does he tell her and
ruin his relationship or does he just
keep quiet don't tell them just don't
[__] tell her that just keep moving
then just if you get caught
bouncing I deny it it was a meet
but I saw you in the shower wasn't me
doesn't mean you got you'll be amazed at
what you can get away with if you just
blatantly lie to the bitter end
like no it is amazing I mean I've gotten
this far on YouTube what if she sees the
marks on your shoulder not that so I
usually heard the word to me really I
don't want to say what I said just move
on what did you say no because that's
you wanna you don't want anyone who's
listening to be a bit you know
oh so previous girlfriends might be like
oh my I don't want people to find out I
make a text messages about no he I mean
we've seen what happened after smash-up
loss means okay this one's actually a
really good one hello Brian and McKenna
and JJ my name is please don't say my
name genuinely don't say his name let's
call this guy I think he says some Henry
sure him Henry great whenever I mean
he's just continued versity and whenever
I meet new people their first impression
of me always seems to be that I'm a
terrorist
but making a bad first impression I feel
that's a strange person told me feel
like that many people terrorists I'm
just I'm just radical like that oh yeah
what are you radical like he's the
opposite basically this guy gets
racially profiled by other people he's
an Asian Muslim he's 17 because of this
I find it quite difficult to get any
girls as I seem to have a very bad first
impression [__] I really I can't really
shave my beard because it's part of my
religion any suggestions any help how
does he dress though how did yeah I mean
they here maybe could tweak that over
the orange jumpsuit
he wears doesn't help I feel like maybe
um take the bomb off your chest for a
stop me yeah well this
in case this is an insurance policy I
mean I say if you have like a big penis
maybe what thou Jesus whip your [__] out
I mean that is that that is one way to
make people think not a terrorist
sex offender really definitely what
you're killing people compared to just
scaring you just scaring offense down to
just scare intimidated a few women with
my penis but never have I blown up
thousands of people to be fair in a
sense you have blown up thousands of
people but you've never blown up
thousands of people I've right I've
blown a lot of sperm up we all my you my
uni room makes a porn star I'm in my
first year at uni a few months ago and
made him mine discovered that one of my
flatmates at uni was a porn star he's
got videos on pornhub that all our block
have seen and on his website he selling
live webcam sessions for $43 a pop
Kapoor but he doesn't know that we know
whenever he's about dropping references
about it and it's got to the stage where
he's surely gonna pick up on it soon
he's a really [__] awkward guy but
creeps the [__] out of me it's because
he's a porn star and girls on our floor
do you tell him and risk killing his
already low confidence I don't feel like
this guy has low confidence if you're
getting your dick out on camera probably
I mean I'm a pretty confident block and
I don't I don't do that yeah buy porn
stole what does it mean is it like is he
just masturbating yeah it's like a
webcam vibe so yeah I don't know that as
close as a pornstar beaten off on that I
don't know is it gay is it gay to
masturbate alone tell you got caught
doing not recently Aamir Khan Aamir Khan
if beaten off on skype videos come out
woman one partly someone in the family
might have released it so it's bad
enough we'll watch him get knocked clean
out that now he's also getting knocked
out like this the first thing he's
knocked out in a while yes but could
hello
his people are currently going through
all of your videos looking for the
easiest three copyright strikes they
have five sick lord the final question
today is one which I felt personally
disgusted by and it's called the two out
of ten likes me help hello Jordan
Lawrence and ksi I'm 16 and starting
college in September it's great being
around girls again as I went to an
all-boys school was your private school
oh boy so was it a mix yeah yeah okay I
mean there's a whole line of questioning
anyway when was so on I met this girl
and her friend likes me there are two
big problems with this first
she's like a 2 out of 10 on a good day
and second I'm getting close with the
girl I originally met and would like to
get in a relationship with her I can't
get the girl
I don't want away from me basically
we're saying is he's found someone who's
attached himself but he's not attracted
to her personally he writes her a 2 out
of 10
you've got very long a dink is it you
got a strong fake game I'd say yeah I'd
say uh this is a hard one yeah obviously
like the easiest option is to just get
through some well shows how Fame does
change people my time and oh my god
[__] best thing is that in a
situation where you have rated one of
them and you've just thought just let
another one come and join the fight one
of my mates is Paul's with you I'll tell
you afterwards amazing ask about the
three semi-hard and I thought now think
which one those peoples probably what
would you do if I'm just a little bit
disappointed because I thought I was
probably the most
like sick minded youtuber Isaac no but I
wasn't thinking about that I was
thinking maybe you know pi-1 off get
with the he was like not just come one
come all
yeah the role advisor speak just knock
bring our own in alright well I thought
that went really well let's welcome back
any for to part three it's a big story
for us million subscribers as everyone
[__] knows care size channel in the
link in the description below
oh come on like there's people watching
this guy know this case I if you are a
new subscriber from Jordy just put in
the comments Jordy said Lauren sent me I
just want to know I've got all the crowd
as well though so you never know it's a
good point they what may want to see the
threesomes go down one day who knows
so yeah appreciated me on probably be me
favorite podcast we've ever done [__]
honestly it's be a min do I like the
video stay subscribed to our YouTube
channel I choose all that [__] that's in
the description thanks for watching and
we'll see us lair